Oh
the heartbreaking moment as the spire of
nacho Dom topples into the flames
[Music]
as onlookers gasp in disbelief in the
heart of the French capital a beloved
icon consumed before their eyes late
afternoon smoke was seen rising from the
Ile de la city soon billowing into the
clear blue sky then the horrifying sight
of flames licking the roof of the
cathedral completely out of control
Parisians gathered looking on powerless
and in horror
the spire or flesh the French fur dart
has pierced this skyline for centuries
but no longer architectural masterpiece
cultural landmarks celebrated in
literature and on film if you come to
Paris you visit the Matra dom as much as
the Eiffel Tower the grief caused by
this sickening sight will be felt far
beyond Paris everybody's just shocked I
think they're just you know
trying to to have this kind of last
moment with no today as you can hear
it's very quiet voices are being raised
much above a murmur here and people have
been here for hours now looking on in
stunned disbelief the mood is one of
subdued shock and that I think is being
felt across this city already almost in
a sense of mourning about what they've
lost this was meant to be the nice the
president of France would go on
television hoping to resolve its
political crisis and unrest but that's
been cancelled now politics eclipsed by
a national tragedy that will only deepen
the sense of malaise gripping this
country Domenic wire corn Sky News in
Paris